there's no official information about
any plans any arrangements we don't know
when we're going to leave
jane palabatko is under lockdown in
shanghai after the ukrainian tested
positive for kovitt
she was taken to this quarantine center
at the shanghai expo here there are
about 15 000 beds but across the city
millions are also isolating at home
there are no showers here and we're not
allowed to receive
any parcels from the outside world two
years ago the world watched china impose
lockdowns with baited breath anxious to
see if the country would be able to
contain this new coronavirus but dr
isaac bogach says things are much
different today we're not really
concerned about importing more virus we
already have enough of it here and we're
really in a very different stage of the
pandemic than they are thanks to
widespread uptake of mainly mrna
vaccines still cases of covit are up
once again in many parts of the country
suggesting that canada has now entered a
sixth wave we really cannot say
what our new case numbers are we are
seeing
hospitalizations rising four percent
uh in the last week fueled by the ba2
omicron sub variant experts expect this
wave will bring more hospitalizations
and sadly more deaths but it isn't
expected to overwhelm health systems as
much as previous waves and for now no
canadian jurisdictions are even hinting
widespread public health measures could
be reimposed we're keeping a sharp eye
on it i always recommend people to be
cautious getting boosters masking and
staying home when sick compared to a
city in lockdown a relatively small
price to pay heather urex west global
news calgary